françoise après la joie d'enregistrer
vous avez découvert la joie de chanter
en scène oui je peux dire que j'ai
découvert parce qu'au début vraiment
j'aimais pas ça faisait mais pas ça
c'est uniquement parce que j'avais très
peur risque en stud me suis toujours
demandé comment vous étiez arrivé à
vaincre votre peur pour monter sur une
scène parce que tout de même la série au
studio peut recommencer quand on
enregistre on peut encore baisser met en
scène la devant le pis quoi que je crois
que l'habitude il fut beaucoup puis
enfin il faut se dire qu'on est là parce
qu il ait voulu être français je crois
est-ce que vous avez davantage peur
quand vous chantez celle des autres que
quand vous chantez vos propres chansons
oh non c'est exactement pareil j'ai j'ai
simplement peur la première fois que le
chanteur est la première fois vous avez
chanté va pas besoin à tambour formule
polie je chantais vapeur pour nathan
bout c'est vraiment atroce parce que
j'ai chanté ça le lendemain du jour de
la première lame pia je n'ai pas voulu
la chanteuse jours de la première parce
que j'avais jamais chanté par un sarde
et j'ai bien du réseau d'ailleurs parce
que le lendemain j'ai eu des tas de
trous dans le texte et l art est
vraiment affreux enfin je me suis
rappelé les paroles au dernier moment
alors je ne sont pas des toujours en
retard sur la mesure annoncée ça si
c'était des troupes parce que vraiment
j'ai mélangé les par tout ça enfin vous
aviez vieilli d'un d'accord ce soir là
alors il avait abandonné cette chanson
en scène ah bah alors j'ai abandonné
pour un mois enfin les ports de bretagne
à la france parce que moi vraiment ça me
gâcher tout à blanc avant d'entrer en
scène je pensais qu'à cette chanson je
me faisais je vais avoir des trous etc
alors
et puis ensuite j'ai chanté l'étrangère
les gens ne la connaissais pas encore
mais j'ai chanté récemment points
deuxième fois alors à lyon et je vais en
fait j'avais pas tellement l'attention
de la chanter mais public était
tellement gentil que que j'ai chanté en
avertissant le public que je risquais
d'avoir beaucoup de trous de mémoire et
j'ai fait un essai je pense que c'est
pour ça que je n'ai pas eu d'accord ça
s'est bien passé
non je suis délivrés bon alors ça y est
maintenant c'est enfin il faut y aller
je peux l'annoncer
alors moi je crois que ce serait la
moindre des choses de dédier au public
lyonnais
cette chanson de maurice vidal à et
jacques dutronc jacques dutronc qui fait
son service militaire savoir voici va
pas prendre à tambour